[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
قال للفيلسوف الالماني شوبنهاور البذائه
تنتصر على اي جدل وتحجب اي دور للعقل
والبذاءه ليست غريبه عن عالم السياسه
والسلطه يستخدمها الموالون والمعارضون
اساس واتباعهم سلاح لفظي كما يعتبرها
البعض وفن كما يراها اخرون فيما تبقى في
اطار قله الادب والعجز بالنسبه الى كثيرين
الشتيمه السياسيه لسنا في صدد التشجيع
عليها ولا الدفاع عن المتفوهين بها لكننا
اليوم سنناقشها في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
فرنسا خلال القرنين الاخيرين ملوك اباطره
ورؤساء اهينوا بغزاره ان عبر الصحافه او
في الشارع او على مواقع التواصل مقالات
شرسه تهكم رسوم ساخره وشتائم في بلاد
الانوار وقبل الثوره عقب بالاعدام كل من
اساء او طعن بالذات الملكيه الى يوم اعدم
فيه الملك شخصيا فاتى قانون عام
1881 لحريه الصحافه مؤطرا قذف الرؤساء
ومعاقبا بالسجن من ثلاثه اشهر الى سنه او
بغرامه ماليه كل من يسيء او يهين رئيس
الدوله الغي هذا القانون عام 2013 ليستبدل
عام 2021 بالماده
433 على 5 من القانون الجنائي يعاقب كل من
يوجه اهانه للشخص يمثل سلطه الدوله او
يشغل منصبا عاما بالسجن عام وبغرامه ماليه
تصل الى 15 الف يورو رغم كل الاطر
القانونيه ازدهر شتم وازدراء ومهاجمه
الرؤساء في الجمهوريه الخامسه في فرنسا
الصحفي اندغيفي في كتابه الجنرال سيموت
وصف دوغول بابشع نعود وكلفه هذا الامر منع
الكتاب وغرام ماليه وثلاثه اشهر حبس اما
وبينما كان يمر امام محتاجين صرخت الجموع
متران انقلع الان فاجاب يا للسجع لكنها
قافيه ضعيفه وفي 2001 واثناء زيارته لقريه
فرواه نعت احد المواطنين رئيس شيراك
بالوغد فاجابه تشرفنا انا ادعى شكشيراك
وفي 2002
قام احد الحضور بضرب فرنسوا بيرو بكعكه
على وجهه وفي 2011 شد احد المواطنين
الرئيس الكوزي من كتفه اثناء تجوله في
الشارع في مدينه براكس عام بعد ذلك رش
الرئيس فرنسا اولامب بالطح اثناء القائه
خطابا في مقر منظمه القصف ياخ عام 2017
استخدمت طحين مجددا ولكن هذه المره في
استهدافا للمرشح وفي العام نفسه صفع مرشح
اخر للرئاسه وهو من مدينه اما الرئيس
الحالي لمانيا فله حصه الاسد في
الانتقادات والشتائم التي وصلت احيانا حد
الاعتداءات الجسديه كالبيضه التي وقعت على
راسه عام 2017 حين كان مرشحا للرئاسه
يتجول في معرض الزراعه او الصفعه التي
تلقاها في تايلور عام 2021 الى اخر قضيه
ضاج بها الراي العام الفرنسي حيث كتبت
احدى المواطنات على مواقع التواصل واصفه
بالقمامه فتم تحقيق معها واستدعائها امام
القضاء بتهمه اهانه شخص في منصب رسمي فهل
شتم الرؤساء وانتقادهم والتهجم عليهم يمكن
ان يدخل اطار حريه التعبير ام انه يقلل من
هيبه هذه المناصب والدول التي تمثلها
وما الحد الفاصل بين الشتيمه السياسيه
وقله الاخلاق
الشتيمه السياسيه في فلك الممنوع وابدا من
بروكسل مع الكاتب المغربي محمد بن ميلود
اهلا بك محمد انت حاليا مقيم في بلجيكا
اريد ان اطرح عليك في البدايه سؤال بسيط
من ضمن
الانتقادات التي قمت بتوجيها للنظام في
المغرب وصفط النظام المغربي
بالعصابه التي تمتص دم الشعب المغربي
البسيط كما انك يعني في كتاباتك ايضا
عندما تحدثت عن الملك طبعا الملك بشكل عام
ان تكون ملكا يعني ذلك انك انسان بائس
ووحيد وبلا صديق واحد لا يمكن لملك ان
يصادق شخصا من عامه الرعيه هذا انتقاص من
شانه اليوم يعني كل هذه الكتابات يمكن ان
تدخل اطار الاساءه او الاهانه
السياسيين الحكيمين او حتى احيانا قد تصل
الى شخص الملك
لماذا تلجا الى هذا الاسلوب
وما الثمن الذي تدفعه ازاء لجوءك لهذا
الاسلوب تحياتي
طبعا
للاسف نحن نعيش داخل الانظمه
ارهابيه مخيفه لا تعترف بحريه التعبير ولا
تقبل النقد هذا مجرد نقد بسيط ولكن للاسف
في شعوبنا
الثمن الذي قد ندفعه غالي جدا ولابد من
دفع هذا الثمن والا الى الابد
طيب ولكن اليوم هناك اساليب اخرى يعني
تتحدث عن حريه التعبير هناك خط فاصل يفصل
بين حريه التعبير ربما والاساءه او التهجم
على شخصيات سياسيه لماذا اليوم انت تربط
حريه التعبير بتخطي هذا الخط الفاصل يعني
بالنسبه اليك اليوم الاهانه هي حريه تعبير
او الاساءه هي حريه التعبير
اين توجد الاساءه في الكلام الذي كتبته
عزيزتي هذا وصف دقيق هؤلاء عصابه عباره عن
عصابه
هذا وصف هذه ليست اساءه
بل هذا وصف جد مهذب في حقهم انت تعتبر
انما قلته هو وصف مع العلم انك عندما تصف
شخصا ما بالسارق او بالعصابه او بالحرامي
فهذه اهانه لهذا الشخص ولكن الاشخاص الذين
يستخدمون اليوم الشتيمه السياسيه هل تعتبر
ان هذا من حقهم اليوم لو كانوا معارضين
لنظام او حتى موالين استخدام الشتائم
السياسيه برايك هو حريه التعبير ام لا
طبعا اكيد من يحدد اين تقف الخطوط الحمراء
للغه
من الذي يقول هذا الكلمه حلال وهذه الكلمه
حرام
يا عزيزتي اقول لك شيئا بسيطا لا توجد
بداءه اكثر من الاستبداد اكثر من الظلم
اكثر من الطغيان اكثر من رمي الناس في
السجون اكثر من تفقير الشعوب المحصقه هذه
البداء الحقيقيه
وبرايك اليوم هل تخاف بعض الانظمه ربما من
الانتقاد اللاذع او من ما يعرف بالشتائم
السياسيه
كل الانظمه المغاربيه والعربيه وبصفه عامه
الانظمه الديكتاتوريه المتخلفه التي ما
زالت تعيش وتنتعش في زمن الذكاء الصناعي
والجيل الخامس للاسف كلها تخاف من النقد
لانها هشه لانها مبنيه بدون قانون لا تملك
اي شيء تملك فقط العصا والسجون وبالتالي
لا يمكنها ان تقبل صوتا حرا او نقدا او
معارضه الامر واضح جدا نعم سيد محمد ولكن
يعني هذا النقاش ايضا موجود في يعني اعرق
الديمقراطيات في العالم اليوم مساله
الشتيمه السياسيه تطرح اشكاليه حقيقيه
للمدافعين عنها وللمن يهاجمها دعني اذهب
الى القاهره لنتعرف على ضيفنا الثاني في
هذه الحلقه اذا النائب السابق في البرلم
المصري المحامي والمستشار القانوني السيد
صلاح حسب الله اهلا بك سيد صلاح انت من
يعني من موقعك كيف تقارب الشتيمه السياسيه
التي قد تطال الرؤساء او الملوك او الحكام
او حتى السياسيين اولا صباح الخير واسمحي
لي بس ان انا اولا انه يعني اضع ثابت في
الحديث ومبدا ان هو ما فيش حد على فكره دي
حريه التعبير وحريه ابداء الراي وبالعكس
على فكره احنا احنا بندعم هذا الاتجاه وفي
في مصر
هناك مساحات
متاحه للجميع لابداء الراي
وانتقاد النظام وانتقاد
المؤسسات السياسيه زي البرلمان وخلافه
انما زي ما متفق معك
استاذ الفاضله ان في خطوط فاصله ما بين
حريه الداء الرائي والديمقراطيه وممارستها
وبين التجاوز المحتوى على السب والقصد ما
فيش حاجه بتقول على فكره
وبالتالي مثلا قد تكون البذاء ربما هي جزء
من اسلوب في التعبير
لا على الاطلاق على الاطلاق انا انا هذكر
لحضرتك في في البرلمان المصري في احد
الجلسات السابقه في الفصل التشريعي
المنتهي احد النواب داخل المجلس قام وقلب
بمنتهى الصراحه وفي كلمه منقوله على
الهواء انا لا اثق في رئيس الجمهوريه ولا
احب رئيس الجمهوريه ولا كذا هذا رايه انما
لو تجاوز لفظا هنا بقى يقع تحت طيله
القانون يعني هنا ما تبقاش ممارسه لحريه
راس او حريه تعبير هو لما قال كده على
فكره لم لم يؤخذ منه اي اجراء السخريه غير
مقبوله يعني هناك فنون في هذا العالم فن
السخريه تهكم هناك يعني الكاريكاتير هناك
حتى بعض الممثلين يقومون بمسرحيات هزليه
قد يسخرون من رؤساء ومن ملوك يعني هذا
القانون الذي تتفضل به يدع حدود لهذه
الحريه في التعبير التي تتعلق بهذه بهذه
الشريحه من الناس والدليل ان في مصر مثلا
هناك الكثير من المخرجين او الكثير من
الفنانين الذين سجنوا بسبب اغاني انتقدوا
فيها او بشكل لاذع طبعا السلطه الحاكمه
وشخص رئيس الجمهوريه وبالتالي انت بالنسبه
اليك يعني تكلم ولكن بحدود تتكلم ولكن
بوصول وبضوابط قانونيه لا ترتكب مخالفه
للقانون وانت بتبدي رايك وعايز اقول
لحضرتك حاجه احنا مثلا كجيل تربينا تربينا
على الكاريكاتير الساخر من بعض مؤسسات
النظام عبر الكاتب الراحل احمد رجب كان
كاتب ساخر وكان في جورنال الاخبار اللي هو
جرنان يعني بيصدر عن مؤسسه قوميه حكوميه
رسوم مصطفى حسين الكاريكاتريه تربينا على
ان هناك مساحه متاحه لانتقاد النظام
السفريه
دون ممار لو خرج شخص في الشارع كما حصل
هنا في فرنسا وشتم رئيس الجمهوريه او صفعه
ما الذي سيحصل لهذا الشخص
اعدام
قانوني اجراء قانوني حازم في اطار القانون
مش في اطار هواء رئيس الجمهوريه او اتجاه
رئيس الجمهوريه او انزعاج رئيس الجمهوريه
في اطار قانون العقوبات في المواد 179
يعني التاطير القانوني طب محمد كنت تقول
قبل ان اتعرف على ضيفنا الثالث كنت تقول
ماذا محمد
الاعدام يعني الاعدام من الدوحه في قطر
الكاتب والباحث والدكتور في علم النفس
الاجتماعي السيد عزام امين اهلا بك دكتور
عزام كتبت مقاله عنوانها دفاعا عن الشتيمه
لماذا تدافع عنها عندما تكون سياسيه طبعا
تتحدث عن الشتائم السياسيه وانت ربطت هذه
الشتائم بمرحله ما عرف بالربيع العربي
مرحبا ميسلون مرحبا بك وبضيوفك 24
اول شيء انا بتفق مع ضيفك محمد بن ميلود
بن بروكسل حقيقه يعني ما بعرف في ظل
الاستبداد اي حريه هي موجوده وايديمقراطيه
هي موجوده خلينا نتفق انه كل الانظمه
العربيه
واشدد على ال التعريف يعني هي انظمه
استبداديه والخطوط الحمراء التي تستخدمها
يعني كما قال ضيفك من مصر ضيفك الفاضل من
مصر نحن مع الحريه ولكن هذه لكن الذي تمحي
كل ما قبلها نحن مع حريه المراه ولكن مع
حريه الاعلام ولكن نحن مع الديمقراطيه
ولكن هذه لكن تمحي كل ما قبلها نعود الى
سؤالك يعني طبعا بخصوص مصر يعني تحيه الى
الطبيب المصري هاني سليمان الذي اعتقل
الاسبوع الماضي وهو طبيب ومخبر وعفوا
وتسويق وخبير تسويق اعتقل الاسبوع الماضي
وزجه في سجن ابو زعبل بتهمه
اشاعات كاذبه يعني الانتماء لجماعات
ارهابيه يعني اصبحت قوانين الاعلام
والحريه وقوانين
الاخلاقيه هاي اللي بيستخدمها صوت في يد
الانظمه العربيه كلها
لجلد المواطن وجلد الشعب
يعني بشكل عام يعني طبعا انظمه انقلابيه
والشتيمه هناك
انا حبيت حبيت
يا
السيده ميسلون من يحدد ما هو اخلاقي وما
هو غير اخلاقي اذا كان الواقع بذيء اذا
كان الواقع بذيء فليس يعني من المعيب ان
نواجه هذا الواقع بنفس البزاءه لنعود الى
موضوع الشتيمه وموضوع المقال الذي كتبته
دفاعا عن الشتيمه وكنت ادافع عن الشتيمه
في لبنان وفي سوريا اثناء الانتفاضات
انتفاضات الربيع العربي وانتفاضه لبنان
التي ذبحت للاسف وبقى لبنان لانه هذه
الانتفاضه في لبنان كانت من اجل دوله
مدنيه دوله بكل ما تعني الكلمه من معنى
يعني اتهموا لبنانيين ببذائه اللسان ماذا
تريدون ان يقول لبنانيون في وجه نظام
عباره عن امراء حرب وطوائف
ها
سيدتي عندما يكون
جماعه من الناس مئات الالاف غاضبين
مقهورين نزلوا الى الشوارع هل يجب ان
اعطيهم قاموس ما المفروض ان يستخدموا
ككلمات والمفروض الا يستخدموك كلمات اجمل
شعار في الثوره اللبنانيه هو هيلا هيلا
يعبر عن مدى القهر الذي يعيشه المواطن
اللبناني عن مدى الاسى عن مدى الاحباط
الذي يعيشه المستوى اللبناني يعني انا
استغرب ان نطالب الشعوب ان نطالب الشعوب
باحترام قوانين اخلاقيه فيكتوريه بيضاء
والانظمه لا تحترم هذه الشعوب يعني اما
امراء حرب او انظمه استبداد وانقلاب يعني
تعالي نذهب الى تونس مثلا
والمرسوم 54 الذي اصدره الرئيس قيس سعيد
على مقاسه تماما على مقاسه يعني وكل من
ينتقده انت خرقت القانون وانت لم تحترم
القانون وهكذا يعني لدينا الناشطه شيماء
عيسى نور الدين البح في السجون وغيرهم
المئات والالاف من الصحفيين والمثقفين
وطلاب الجامعات سواء في مصر في تونس في
المغرب في المغرب لدينا يعني انا التحيه
للاخ محمد بن المولدي واتمنى ان يكون ناصر
الزفزافي باحلى بالميلود عفوا بافضل حال
يعني
نحن اليوم في كل الدول العربيه ولكن اليوم
يعني هناك اشخاص متهمه بامور اخرى نحن
نتحدث عن الاشخاص التي تلجا الى الشتم
ونريد ان نسال هنا هناك دراسات كثيره تشير
اليوم محمد انه يعني من يستخدم او من يلجا
الى شاتمه وشخص فعليا عاجز يعني هذا يدل
عن عجز عن ربما نقص في ثقافه الانتقاد
يعني هل استبدلنا اليوم ثقافه الانتقاد
والنقد بثقافه الشتيمه والسب نحن عاجزون
لذلك
الشتيمه لاننا
عاجزون لاننا غير محميون باي قانون لان
كلما زاد الاستبداد زاد الشتم
وليس في موقف القوي
لا نريد ان نكون ان ننطر لثقافه الشتيمه
طبعا هذا ليس شيئا جميلا ولكن
عندما نتحدث في دول فيها القانون
حينها يمكن ان اتفق معك ولكن عندما نواجه
عصابات مسلحه
بالمال والسلطه
وتقذف بكل من يتكلم الى قعر السجون
بماذا ستواجهات السلطه وانت اعزال
للاسف هؤلاء لا يريدون خيرا لشعوبنا
يريدون الشر لتلك البلدان وانت ترين يا
عزيزي الذي حدث وما الذي سيحدث والاخ من
مصر تحدثت عن القانون اين هو القانون وكل
المصريين الاحرار في السجون
اين هو القانون قانون على من يطبق لماذا
لا تطبقون هذا القانون على الرئيس اولا ثم
على تلك العصابات من الفاسدين الذين
ينهبون ثروات ويسرقون الشعب
تطبقنا القانون فقط على الفقراء
وعلى الاحرار الذي نعبر على الصحفيين
يا عزيزتي تخاف من صحفي
تفضل بما ترد يعني اليوم يسال سؤال ربما
قد يكون يعني ليس الوحيد محمد بن ميلود
الذي يطرح هذا السؤال انه اليوم هل يطبق
القانون على اضعف الناس لماذا لا يطبق هذا
القانون مع العلم ان يعني الساسه حتى في
الدول العربيه غالبا ما يلجاون الى
البذاءه في تعاملاتهم حتى مع بعضهم البعض
هناك حوادث كثيره تسجل وبالتالي هل يطبق
القانون على الاضعف كما طرح السؤال سيد
محمد تفضل تكلم عن الحاله المصريه يعني مش
مش حابب ان انا اخود في في احوال دول لم
لم ادرس طبيعه ممارسه سياسيه فيها زي الاخ
عزام اللي اتكلم وهو قطر اظن
اتكلم عن بعد
يعني عموما هو اتكلم عن بعض
مش عارف هو من اي دوله انما اتكلم عن بعض
الاحوال
اللي في بعض الدول وهو لا يلامس ولا
يتعايش مع طبيعه هذه الدول ومع الحاله
السياسيه واللي ومدى تطبيق القانون فيها
من عدمه انا عايز اقول لك بس هنا اهوت
احنا في مصر في الحاله المصريه القانون
بيطبق على الجميع رئيس ومواطن المساله
بيحكمها اطار قانون يطبق على الجميع اذا
خالف الرئيس يسال امام مجلس النواب اذا
خالف مواطن بيساعد امام المحاكم اذا ارتكب
الرئيس ما يعتد به كمخالفه قانونيه يساعد
امام المحاكم وده على فكره يمكن التعديلات
التشريعيه اللي حدثت في قانون العقوبات
الاخير احنا هنا ما بنقولش على فكره ان
القانون يبقى
بيطبق على الهواء السياسي القانون بيطبق
على الجميع في دوله القانون وفي جمهوريه
جديده بنبنيها في الدوله المصريه
بنقول السيد والحاكم فيها هو القانون هذا
الانتقال هذا الانتقال يا سيدتي يحتاج الى
وقت ويحتاج الى ايمان بممارسه الديمقراطيه
ان المساله ان انا عشان انا عاجز ان انا
اخرج ما خلاص يعني مش قادر اعمل حاجه غير
ان انا اتوجه بالسب وامارس في شتائم
يعني اليوم تشير الكثير من الدراسات وكتب
يعني كثر مما نظروا في الشتيمه السياسيه
معتبرين ان شتيمه السياسيه تزدهر في
الديمقراطيات عكس ما يمكن ان يعني
ان يعتقد البعض سيد عزم تريد ان تقول شيئا
ما ربما تفضل بدي علق على كلام الاخ من
مصر الحبيبه يعني وطبعا نحن نتمنى الحريه
لمصر ونتمنى ان تكون من افضل دول العالم
لانه مصر بالنسبه لنا هي غاليه علينا يعني
حين تمنعون انا عم بحكي على جميع الانظمه
العربيه حين يمنع المواطن العربي من
عمل النقاب الحر من عمل الحزب الحر من
التظاهر من التعبير عن رايه بحريه حين
تفرض عليه قوانين جارئه جائره عفوا ومع كل
ذلك يعاني من الفقر ويعاني من القهر ماذا
تطلبون منه ماذا تريدون منه اعود اليك
سيده ميسلون فعل الشتيمه هو فعل عابر
للثقافه يعني موجود بكل الثقافات وموجود
بكل اللغات يعني حقيقه لا توجد ثقافه تخلو
من الشتيمه يعني والشتيمه لها انواع ولها
فنون موجوده يعني هي حاله يعني هي حاله
تعبير عن غضب تعبير عن قهر طبعا هي حاله
العاجز ولكن اثناء الثورات كما هي الحال
فقط لعام 2011 2012 اريد ان اشير فقط
للمشاهدات للمشاهدين نحن لسنا في اطار
مناقشه الشتيمه في الاطار يعني في اطار
الشخصي او العلاقات الفرديه نناقش الشتيمه
السياسيه فقط اريد ان اعيد واوضح تفضل ايه
تماما تماما شتيمه شتيمه سياسيه هي شتيمه
سياسيه عم بحكي عنها يعني اثناء الثورات
تكون الشتيمه السياسيه وخصوصا اذا كان
جماهيريه فعل مقاومه فعل مقاومه ضد الخوف
ضد القهر فعل تمردي فعل تمردي يعني
البارحة البارحه تمت مقاطعه الرئيس ماكرون
في خطابه في لا هاي مجموعه من الفرنسيين
قاطعوه وكتبوا له على لافته انه رئيس
محتجين كتبوا له على لافته انه رئيس
النفاق والعنف طيب ماذا كان رد ماكرون هل
هذا الامر من هيبه الدول انا على فكره على
فكره
على فكره انا لست مؤيد لماكرون ولست مؤيد
لحزبه ولا انتخبه ابدا يعني وبالعكس هو
خصم السياسي ولكن هناك فرق بين الخصم
السياسي والعدو يعني هو ليس عدو وانما خصم
السياسي هل اعود الى سؤالك يعني طبعا
ماكرون كيف واجه المحتاجين قال لهم هذا
حقكم التظاهر حقكم وما كتبتوه وهذه
اللافته تضمنها الديمقراطيه لكم الاخ صلاح
قال انه يتم اعدامه
محمد قال هيك اخص صلاح قال يخدع للقانون
الاخ محمد قال يعدم وهذا يعني هذا لا
اتوقع انه سيحصل يعني يعني سيعدم طبعا في
كل اي دوله عربيه لا يمكن ان نقترب من
شخصيه الرئيس هل هناك علاقه بين الرئيس
وهيبه الدوله يعني لماذا تكون هيبه الدوله
من هيبه الرئيس هيبه الدوله من هيبه
مواطنيها طيب هيبه الدوله من الحريه من
المؤسساتها من هيبه جامعاتها وليس من هيبه
الديمقراطيات وساسال محمد هناك قوانين
تؤطر هذا النوع من الممارسات يعني اليوم
حتى في فرنسا انه الشخص الذي يتبؤ منصب
رسمي ان كان رئيس او ان عاملا في المطافئ
او عاملا في اي اي منصب رسمي لا يمكن ان
تتم اهانته او توجه شتيمه له دون ان يحاسب
الشخص المرتكب باي اي شكل من اشكال
الشتيمه او الاهانه طب ما هذا اليوم ايضا
يعني هو تاطير لهذه الامور لماذا ننتقد
هذه الاطر القانونيه في الدول العربيه ولا
ننتفقدها في دول تصنف نفسها ديمقراطيه
عندما تعيش في دوله ديمقراطيه
وتنتهك القانون فانت تتحمل المسؤوليه
وستعاقب على قدر
خطائك انا اتسائل
بقمح على ذلك الشخص الذي صفع ماكرون
ثمانيه عشر شهرا اعتقد
ومخففه
تخيل ما كان سيحدث له لو انه صفع حاكما
عربيا لو انه صفح السيسي مثلا ارتفع عنف
يعني انت اليوم
كانك تقول انه يعني يجب صفع هؤلاء الاشخاص
ولكن اللجوء الى الصفح او الضرب او هو
اللجوء الى العنف في النهايه كما ان
الشتيمه هي عنف لفظي اليوم يعني استمراريه
الشتيمه نشتم في البدايه ومن ثم نضرب هل
هذا ما نريده اصلا هل هذه هي المعارضه
اتمنى انك تخليني نكمل المذاكره
لا اريد ان تقوليني ما لم اقل انا لا ادعو
الى صفعي احد انا اقول لك ماذا حدث شخص
صفع رئيسا
وهناك قانون لست
انا او انت
تعرف العنف هناك دوله وهناك قانون
وكل من اخترق هذا القانون يتحمله مسؤوليته
الناس ناضجون هذه الخطابات الاخلاق قويه
توجد فقط في شعوبنا بكل وضوح انا اتساءل
لو ان شخصا صفع لا انا لا اطلب ان الناس
يمشوا الرؤساء احدا ولكن سؤال لو ان ما
حدث في فرنسا حدث في مصر او في تونس او في
العراق او في المغرب الى اخره من هذه
الدول
المتشابهه لا يوجد فرق بين مصر والمغرب
وتونس وليبيا والعراق وسوريا لا يوجد فرق
المشترك هذه الديكتاتوريات لمسا بني يوما
على قانون لم تعيش التوراه ثقافيه اولا ما
زالت مبنيه على فكر استبداد ابوي ذكوري
يقمع الجميع وياخذ السلطان بالعنف ياخذها
بالانقلابات ياخذها بالسلاح ولا يؤمن ابدا
بتداول السلطه وبالتالي لا يؤمن بالنقد
هذه الانظمه تقضي على المعارضين بالسلاح
فكيف ستتحدث عن القانون وهي اول من يدوس
هذا القانون بالمناسبه
الصديق
تحدث عن الزفزافي وانا اطرح سؤال لماذا
يقبع شخص مثل الزفزافي الى اليوم
ليس موضوع هذه الحلقه على اي حال ولكن
يعني هذا من حقك ان تطرح السؤال الذي تشاء
ولكن يعني دعنا فقط كي نبقى في مساله
الشتيمه السياسيه سيد صلاح حسب الله كيف
تعقب على ما تفضل به محمد يعني اليوم هو
اعطى مقاربه في مساله ما تعرض له الرئيس
الفرنسي الذي صفع من قبل احد المواطنين
هذا المواطن حكم عليه بالسجن 18 شهرا كيف
تقارب يعني هذه المساله اليوم من وجهه نظر
لو حصلت في دوله عربيه انا برضو معرفش
اللصوص القانونيه الحاكمه او الضابطه لمثل
هذا التجاوز في
قوانين الدول العربيه الاخرى انما انا
هقول لك قولا واحدا ورد بالقانون انا
كرامه بالقانون هرد بالقانون احنا عندنا
ماده 179 من قانون العقوبات بتنص على انه
يعاقب بالحبس كل من اهان رئيس الجمهوريه
بالغرامه التي لا تزيد عن خمسين الف جنيه
وبالحبس من يوم الى ثلاث سنوات على اقصى
تقدير يعني ادي ادي القانون بيقول يعني مش
انا اللي بقول القانون اللي بيقول مساله
بقى ان انا احاول ان انا يعني يعني استخدم
ميزان خاص
لميزان لقياس او لوزن الحاله السياسيه
اقول لا ده بيحصل في فرنسا وما بيحصلش في
الدول العربيه وهكذا دي مساله على فكره
منافيه للحقيقه احنا ما بندعيش على فكره
ان احنا الناس بقت ديمقراطيه الديمقراطيه
في فرنسا ما بندعيش ان احنا الناس بقت
الديمقراطيه في امريكا انما احنا كدوله
واحنا في الوطن العربي على فكره هناك
اراده حقيقيه لان احنا ناخد خطوات في طريق
الديمقراطيه وده اللي بتعمله مصر على فكره
احتمال يسمى مصطلح الجمهوريه الجديده
الجمهوريه الجديده
يعني لماذا اليوم يجب ان يخصص رئيس
جمهوريه بقانون له علاقه بالاساءه لماذا
لا يكون القانون ربما يشمل كل المواطنين
بصفه ان رئيس الجمهوريه وايضا مواطن مصري
هذا الكلام
العقوبات موجوده
نصوص كثيره بتاع الحق المواطن قبل حقائق
الرئيس وفي نفس الوقت بتحمي حق مؤسسات
الدوله وهيبه مؤسسات الدوله القانون على
فكره
بالنسبه اليك اليوم تربط الرئيس بهيبه
الدوله يعني ما يتعرض له الرئيس لا
لا يعني هي المساله المساله على فكره
الرئيس حتى بعد انتخابه مش هو مش هو مبتكر
ايدي الدوله اي الحالي اي رئيس جمهوريه
اليوم
اتى عن طريق اتى عن طريق الصندوق لا
المنصب لو هيبه وليس شخص المنصب رئيس
الدوله لهيبه وليست مؤسسه الدوله لها هيبه
وليس اعضاء هذه المؤسسات انما انا احنا
بنتكلم هنا عن اطار قانوني يحمل مواطن قبل
الرئيس
اللي يزعج الناس في كده لا سنسال هذا
السؤال تفضل استاذ عزام يعني ما الذي يزعج
يعني ان يكون هناك قطر قانونيه تؤطر حريات
التعبير بهذا الشكل وتطبق على المواطن كما
على السياسيين كما تفضل السيد صلاح تفضل
ما هي ما هي للاسف لا تطبق على السياسيين
وخصوصا الموجودين في اعلى الهرم يعني عن
اي اطر نتحدث بمجرد ما نقول ان هناك اطر
فنستطيع ان نستخدم هذه الاطر لجم الحريات
ولجم المعارضه ولجم اي عمل نقدي يعني شوفي
عزيزتي في كل الدول العربيه هناك برلمانات
وهناك نقابات وهناك احزاب مسموح بها ولكن
كلها عباره عن هياكل كرتونيه فارغه لان
الانظمه العربيه هي انظمه استبداديه يعني
انا عن اي خروج عن القانون او على القانون
يتحدث الاستاذ صلاح اليس الخروج على
القانون وعن القانون هي انظمه الانقلابات
العسكريه انا ما بدي احكي عن نظام معين
بدي احكي بشكل عام بدي احكي بشكل عام
الديمقراطيه يجب ان تكون ضمان لاي فرد في
المجتمع ومن حقه ينتقد ومن حقه ان يهاجم
انا لا ادعو المواطنين العرب بصفع رؤسائهم
مع ان الرؤساء كلهم بيستاهلوا يعني بس انا
ما ادعي ولكن ادعي الى ان يكون هناك حريه
تعبير حريه استخدام الكلام حريه الكتابه
حريه التنظيم السياسي يعني هذا ما ادعو
اليه يعني لنتخلق قليلا عن قدسيه الحاكم
لنتخلى قليلا عن التوطنيه يعني قد يعتبره
البعض خطير لماذا لانك اليوم عندما تقول
للناس اوكي اطلقوا الشتائم السياسيه هناك
نوع من التفريغ ايضا
لاي عمل سياسي حقيقي يعني اي عمل نقدي
حقيقي ضد هذه الانظمه التي انت تقول انها
سيئه
عزيزتي عزيزتي ميسلون انا لا اقول للناس
اطلق الشتائم السياسيه اشرح من اين اتت
هذه الشتائم كلما زاد الاستبداد والقمع
ازداد مستوى الشتائم وازدادت بذائتها يعني
في الانظمه الديمقراطيه كفرنسا التي
اعرفها وتعرفينها جيدا هناك شتائم ولكنها
خفيفه نوعا ما اما في الانظمه القمعيه
تزداد الشتائم وتزداد السخريه كيف يفرغ
المواطن العربي قهره من خلال النكات
والمزاح وكلها نكات سياسيه وجنسيه لانه
مقموع مقموع من الانظمه السياسيه ومن
الانظمه الدينيه الموجوده هي عميل للانظمه
السياسيه في كل الدول العربيه تقريبا يعني
فانا لا اقول للمواطن العربي اشتم بالعكس
اذا كان هناك مجال اذا كان هناك مجال طبعا
هو رد فعل رد فعل العاجز كما وصفتيه انت
رد فعل العاجز الضعيف المقهور الممنوع من
اي شيء في لحظه معينه ينفجر
من منا لم يشتم يعني
الاستاذ صلاح هل هل انت شتمت في حياتك اذا
قلت لي لا ساقول لك انت لا تقول الحقيقه
كلنا نشتم في لحظات الغضب كلنا نشتم حين
اعود الى البيت كمواطن عربي وافتح الثلاجه
ويكون ابني عم يبكي او مشتهي ياكل معلش
اشتم فرغ
طيب من حقه يشتم هذا المواطن ما في طعمه
ابنه يعني لماذا هذه السلطانيه
لماذا تبتسم ابتسم انا انا معترض على فكره
ان السب والقصف والشتيمه والتجاوز هو
الطريق الوحيد امام العاجز انا اقول
لحضرتك حاجه احنا عندنا على فكره كان
نموذج هو
حاله
كمل اكمل بس اكمل اكمل احنا كان عندنا
انتخابات صحفيين كان معروف على فكره كان
معروف ان مرشح الاقرب الى الدوله هو
الصديق العزيز المحترم الاستاذ خالد ميري
نزل في انتخابات حره امام احد المعارضين
للنظام او واحد كتاب المعارضه الاستاذ
خالد البلدي
لان في اراده حقيقيه لان الصندوق هو يعكس
ارادته ويعبر عن نفسه حصل لان الصحفيين
انتخبوها المعارض للدوله بمنتهى الوضوء
دون سب ودون قصف وفي اطار ديمقراطي حر
انتخب المعارض او منتقد للدوله في مقابل
صحفيه اخر من المؤسسات الدوله الحكوميه
نحن نتحدث
يوما يتابع الفضاء الالكتروني وهو فضاء
غير مقيد الى حد ما حتى الان يعني مقيد
ولكن يظل اقل تقييدا من الفضاءات الاخرى
في كل العالم يرى ان هناك منسوب ومرتفع من
الشتائم على هذا الفضاء ليس فقط شتائم
سياسيه ولكن بما اننا نتحدث عن السياسيه
هناك مؤثرين اليوم يلجاون فقط الى الشتم
يعني مؤثرين على مواقع التواصل لا اسلوب
لديهم سوى الشتائم والبذاءه وما تقول عنه
قدح وذم في ايصال الافكار السياسيه وهذه
حاله اليوم في العالم العربي بشكل خاص
خاصه بعد ما سمي بالربيع العربي طيب اليوم
نحن كيف نقاربها هل نقاربها بان نقول ان
هناك قوانين وانه يجب ان نمشي على
القوانين ونقطه ام اننا نعترف ان هناك هذا
الواقع ونحاول ان نفهم لماذا هو موجود
وهذا ما قاله السيد عزام اليوم هل تقبل
اليوم انت من موقعك ان تقول ان هناك
استياء وهذا الاستياء قد يدفع برد فعل
منه الشتيمه السياسيه
انا انا عايز بس اعلق على الموضوع ده
باختصار ان ان مزاج المواطن العربي انت
تابعيه من خلال عدد المشاهدات
اللي بيعمل على السوشيال ميديا فيديو بيسب
ويقصف وبيشتم فيه
بتلاقي الناس العدد على فكره بتاع
المشاهدات مثلا عشره ثم بعد ذلك بيقل
لسبعه ثم بعد ذلك خمسه ثم بعد ذلك بينصرف
الجميع عنه لان دي
للمشاهد بيبقى عنده خلاص وصل اليقين ان
هذا ليس لدي حلول ليس لديه طريق جديد هو
ليس لديه الا شتائم والسب والقصر خلاص انا
ممكن ابقى منجذب الى هذا الاسلوب لمره
الاتنين لتلاته بعد كده انما لا يقدم حلول
اطروحات بديله خلاص هتتابعوا ليه يعني مش
هتابع واحد طالع يشتم ليل ونهار انت مع
تغيير القانون في مصر اليوم بما يتعلق
بهذه المساله التي ترتبط بحريه التعبير
وحريه الصحافه وحريه الفن ام لا انا
تعديلات قانونيه تطبق على الجميع بشكل
متساوي من خلال مبدا المساواه بين جميع
المواطنين من اول المواطن لغايه الرئيس في
اطار قانوني يحمل مواطن قبل الرئيس من
السب والقسوه والاهانه وهكذا يحمي من
السبتان محمد بن ميلود اريد ان اسالك
اليوم بالنسبه اليك عندما تجلس مع نفسك مع
قلمك وتفكر متى قد متى قد اتوقف عن
الانتقاد اللاذع عن الشتم او عن استخدام
اللجوء الى شتيمه السياسيه وهل هناك شتيمه
سياسيه اذكى من غيرها ام لا انا لا احب
صراحه لغه الخشب واريد ان اتحدث بشكل واضح
الشعوب العربيه مضطهده
وتشعر
وبالتالي هي تنفس تعبر عن نفسها في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وفي كل مكان
لا تعرف انها مطارده
بالات القمع ولا افهم الى حد الان كيف
يستطيع مثقفون عرب ان يغطوا على هذه
الانظمه الاجراميه التي تقتل الناس بشكل
واضح فنحن اننا عندنا مشكل اخلاقي مع
الشتيمه وليس لدينا مشكل اخلاقي مع
الديكساتوريه مع تفقير الشعوب مع اضطهاد
الناس الشعوب العربيه اليوم اصبحت تهرب
عبر البحر الى اوروبا
طالبه النجاس هذه هي الشتيمه
الحقيقيه التي يجب ان نناقشها اما هذه
الشتيمه التي قد تصدر من هذا او ذاك
احيانا
ان نفهمها في اطار اولا حريه التعبير
لاننا كما قلت عزيزتي لا نتحدث عن شتم
الجار لجاره
الناس بل هذا رد فعل هذا فعل سياسي هذا
فعل مقاومه اقول لك عندما لا يجد المواطن
المغاربي او العربي اي وسيله للتعبير او
التغيير الاستاذ يتحدث عن التغيير وقال
بان هؤلاء يعني لا يغيرون شيئا لانهم فقط
يشتمون علي سؤالا بسيطا وما الذي تغيرونه
انتم الذين تتحدثون لغه الخشب وتدافعون
على هذه الانظمه وتلمعونها وبكل وضوح
واعتذر انا لا اقصد هذا الشخص بشخصين بشكل
عام
هؤلاء يشاركون في الجريمه هؤلاء هم السبب
في بقاء هذه الانظمه الديكتاتوريه الرهيبه
لان المثقفين يغطون عليها لان الفقهاء
يغطون عليها لان اصحاب
الشواهد العليا يغطون عليه لانهم ياكلون
معها ببساطه وبالتالي سيقول لك في مساله
الشتيمه السياسيه قبل ان نختم تفضل
انا لست ضد الشتي السياسيه
بالعكس من ذلك اشجعه الشباب المغاربي
والعربي على شتم هذه الانظمه
وانتقادها والكتابه ضدها وتعريت جرائمها
وهذا حقهم هذا حقهم وهذه هي الحريه التي
نحتاج في شعوبنا حريه النقد
هؤلاء شكرا لك
شكرا لك وصلت فكرتك يعني للاسف للاسف
الوقت انتهى سيد صلاح كلمه مختصره جدا قبل
ان اختم معك استاذ عزام اختصار شديد استاذ
صلاح وبعدين استاذ عزام تفضل
باختصار سريع ما نتحدث به ليست لغه الخشب
هي لغه الاحترام هي لغه الاحترام
الديمقراطيه وحريه الراي قبل احترام
الانظمه السياسيه وعايز بس اقول اذا كنت
انا اطالب الشباب بسبب واشتم وكذا هل
اشاركهم قضاء العقوبه اللي ممكن تقع عليهم
في حاله ارتكابهم السب والقصر يعني لو مش
من منطقه خالص ان انا بقى قاعد مثلا على
شواطئ في شواطئ اسبانيا وطالب الشباب ان
هو يشتم ويتحبس اتفضل استاذ عزام ما حدا
بيحب يهاجر من بلده الا اذا كان مجبر
احييه ضيفك محمد بن ميلود يعني انا مع ان
يتحرر الشعب العربي من قدسيه الحاكم ومن
طلطميه السياسه ومن الخوف من الحاكم انا
اقول الشتيمه من اجل الشتيمه وانما لتتحرر
نفوسهم من من الخوف يعني واعود واكرر كما
قاله ضيفك من بروكسل وهو اكيد مجبر يعني
لا يعاب على وجوده ببروكسل ولا اعاب على
وجودي انا في فرنسا او خارج بلدي لانه لو
كان في بلدي حريه واحتراميلا بقيت في بلدي
يعني ولكن كلمه سريعه يعني كلمه سريعه لو
الان فتحت اوروبا باب الهجره للشعوب
العربيه من سيبقى في هذه الدول العربيه
الاجابه هي اكبر شتيمه اكبر شتيمه للانظمه
العربيه ولا نتعش لنهايه له نترك لك ولك
حريه التعبير وحريه التفكير شكرا جزيلا
للمتابعه دائما
[موسيقى]